I'm Carmel nanjiani I play Steve
Banerjee on welcome to Chippendales and
I'm here with BuzzFeed to play with
kittens
what's your name what's this one's name
Elizabeth
[Music]
what was the question I think whenever
I'll be quiet I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I think whenever we did an actual
performance the background
how excited and into the show they get
so we'd have like men stripping
and during the take I'm talking softly
we would tell the background not to make
any noise because there'd be dialogue
and stuff sometimes and each time they
would yell cut the background would like
go wild and scream and that was exciting
to watch
because after we would do 40 takes a day
same exact performance every single time
the audience would go wild every single
time and just the energy of that was
really exciting you can also see why why
chipping deals was such a success you
know it was great to get to be involved
in all parts of it you know to give like
notes and scripts by the way the writers
were amazing the directors are amazing
but I just enjoyed being a part of
every part of the process being part of
editing giving notes in the script and
then also with the other actors I love
telling them if you have an issue with
anything come to me if you have any
problems I kind of like being the guy
whenever they had a concern or something
a line that they didn't like or they
wanted to change or approach the
character slightly differently or
something so I really I really like that
it's interesting because there isn't
that much material
specifically on the person so I really
approach it like trying to create the
character as it's written it's not a
character like Abraham Lincoln or you
know Elvis or something where people
really know know the person so I knew oh
hi hi London we'll see you're both here
you're both here together I hold my cat
like a baby like this and so
that's how I'm used to holding a cat
thank you
I knew Dan Stevens who's wonderful a
person and actor and wonderful on the
show I knew Dan I've been friends with
Dan for a while and it's sort of always
been like we gotta find a way to work
together but other than him I just sort
of got to know everyone it's truly the
best group of humans and actors I've
worked with you know it was a real joy
to work with actors who were like from
theater and were like serious serious
actors you know I really fell in love
with all of them and it's the first time
I've actually gone to
my cast members for help I've never done
that before if I had a scene I'd go up
to Anna Leon or Murray and be like hey
having trouble with this scene
could you please help me with it and
we'd like sit on the floor and they'd
like help me with the scene so it was
really really wonderful to have people
you love and also actors who've had
experience doing this kind of work that
you could really rely on to carry you
through certain difficult scenes
laughs
I think the experience of getting to
process such a big part of our life and
seeing that those events from each
other's perspectives really for the
first time I think was the best part of
making that movie our experiences were
very very very different and we had just
assumed that they were very similar but
they were shockingly in some ways we had
the opposite experience going through
that hi baby no no no hey come back baby
you're okay you're okay
I'd love to do another rom-com with
Emily but I think you know we have a
couple scripts we've written that are in
you know various stages of getting made
or not made
yeah we we had a great text thread going
I think Anna Lee was always you know
she's oh hi oh
oh who are you Zurich oh Zurich is very
pretty I'm gonna lay down I'm gonna put
you guys here yeah actually was the one
who really she abuses emojis I'll be
honest I think she really overdoes it
but in a very Charming way and now I've
started doing it
oh my God what sweet face you have
oh no I'm in trouble
there's a scene we had in the forest
where you have a fight and I have to do
this like slide that took me 24 tries I
think we got two takes that were good
that was a high and then I loved working
with Leah McHugh so anytime I got to do
scenes with her was very very fun
I just never said anything about the
movie so I don't think I ever spoiled
anything you know I'm a fan of these
movies so I know how strict they are
about that stuff so I I was very careful
I never spoiled anything because they
wanted people to experience it
themselves come back here baby
I'm just friends with Seth and Evan and
one day Evan just texted me and was like
hey do you want to do a cameo for the
boys I was like I love the show Evan
knew that I you know loved the show and
he said okay you have to sing and I was
like I cannot sing I'm not just being
modest I promise you I cannot sing at
all and he said even better and then I
just recorded I saw y'all be quiet
I just recorded a selfie on my phone oh
my God where did where did
but they where's one did we lose one oh
no no no you're okay hi oh look at these
sweet babies this is Zurich right I
think Zurich is trouble
favorite memory I would say they're
doing the last season was very very
emotional for me definitely cried a lot
at the end of that that show really
changed my life and it was such a
wonderful experience and I learned so
much on it it really changed my career
too so I shot the last season while
doing Eternal so I was back and forth
between London and L.A so I think during
the last season of that was very
emotional and especially the last scene
I really really cried a lot and then got
on a plane went to London to do eternals
that was a very special season getting
to do that at the end
oh my God you guys are going to get me
in trouble I love both very intensely
and exactly equally Marvel in Star Wars
I love you both exactly the same and
it's at a very high level
my wife that she thinks something
terrible is happening although if I
called her during this she would really
really freak out
I auditioned for the bad guy in your
highness that ended up going to Justin
Thoreau I was like why did I even
audition that's a very different
very very different person I love Justin
Theroux by the way he's fantastic
I had a very nice watch as Kingo and
eternals it's okay Paris I got you
I got your power so scared
I really
really love succession and I also love
Severance it's a succession or severance
any show with an S I'll I'll be in it
just ask me nicely or ask me in a very
shitty way I'll still do it
Ewan McGregor for sure more Star Struck
by him he's such a good actor he's such
a wonderful person too and he's also
just so beautiful he looked into his
eyes when you're doing a scene and it's
very easy to forget your lines oh
they're falling asleep is this one
asleep yeah they're both asleep oh thank
you BuzzFeed welcome to Chippendales is
on Hulu oh sorry sorry welcome to
Chippendales
Hulu November 22nd it's got no kittens
but you know no show is perfect thank
you heaven on Earth for letting us play
with these absolutely gorgeous kittens
please support your local cat rescue
they all need wonderful homes